on the 30th of September 2007 a man
named garry kasparov declared he would
run against vladimir putin's hand-picked
successor in the presidential election
in russia his platform was simple
he led a coalition of anti-putin groups
called the other Russia and they vowed
to establish a democratic and just
government less than two months later
garry kasparov Russian presidential
candidate was arrested at a Moscow rally
by police loyal to Vladimir Putin
Russian president last night on the 9th
of October 2016 in the United States of
America on live national television
Donald Trump American presidential
candidate stared at his opponent and
said quote if I win I'm going to
instruct my Attorney General to get a
special prosecutor to look into your
situation we're going to get a special
prosecutor and we're going to look into
it because you know what people have
been their lives have been destroyed for
doing 1/5 of what you've done
Secretary Clinton replied quote it's
just awfully good that someone with the
temperament of Donald Trump is not in
charge of the law in our country Trump
then erased any doubt what he meant or
who he is or what he has planned he shot
back quote because you'd be in jail make
no mistake what you heard between the
sniffs and the snorts and the mindless
wandering around the stage
make no mistake what you heard him in
the swirling strutting egotism and the
cacophony of insults make no mistake
what you heard and put aside for now
even the lie about opposing Iraq and the
mindless heartless claim that captain
Khan would still be alive if Trump had
been president then put aside even the
disavowal of his own running mates
position on Syria and the bobbing and
weaving about the grab them by the [ __ ]
tape you heard a would-be President of
the United States the 28th different
nominee in the long history of his party
for the most important job on earth who
heretofore has left this ominous dire
dictatorial threat of jail to the
bleating of his ravenous rally crowds
you heard Donald Trump threatened to not
merely defeat his opponent but then to
put her in prison instruct my Attorney
General
special prosecutor because you'd be in
jail
make no mistake what you heard there are
no other conclusions here Trump are
there it is not the presidency you are
running for not at least the presidency
as we have known it since 1789 not at
least as we have known it as a free
country the kind of presidency you want
to have Trump already exists it is
called a Putin style dictatorship and
the kind of America you want to lead
Trump is not the America we live in now
this other America already exists it is
called Russia Trump men and women you
often invoke but none of whom you have
ever understood for a moment have died
for this country in order to prevent you
they have died and others have lived and
sacrificed in other ways to prevent
exactly the kind of one-man rule in
which a president or a candidate for
president can threaten to imprison his
opponent all the Patriots of our
hallowed history have given and lost and
self-abnegation so that you could not
say that last night and they have also
given all of themselves so that Hillary
Clinton could not have looked at you
last night and said you bragged about
sexual assault on that tape if elected I
will appoint a special prosecutor to
investigate you so that she could not
look at you Trump and say you just
admitted to writing off nine hundred and
sixteen million dollars in losses to
avoid taxes if I'm elected I'll appoint
a special prosecutor to investigate you
but she didn't say either of those
things because she believes in our
democracy and our democracy rests on the
same razor's edge that has permitted a
bully and a lunatic like you to get this
close to having the power to destroy it
because it is very simple Trump because
you personally threatened to put Hillary
Clinton in jail last night when you made
her potential imprisonment part of your
campaign in your own words you killed a
part of our democracy when you
threatened to jail one of your political
opponents you have threatened to jail
all of your political opponents it is by
itself the outskirts of a Russian pseudo
democracy in which the very act of
opposition to the rule
becomes a crime or worse yet it becomes
a reason to fabricate evidence of an
extant crime against the opponent it is
dictatorship and the power you seek
might still carry the title president
but with the threat of the legal power
of the United States of America being
brought down on your opponents you might
as well be Chancellor Trump or chairman
Trump or a protector Trump or
Generalissimo Trump or a Fuhrer Trump
because you'd be in jail because Trump
if you are elected we would all be in
jail your threat last night to merge
political opposition with legal
prosecution has no place in a free
country and you Trump have no place in
this free country
that's the closure I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space